[Music]
Wow
so this is where all the nostalgia
critic episodes were filmed here years
ago you got it but though because
everything is saying to preserve in
history
look at all the reviews that they did
there Shrek there's Schindler's List
saves Christmas and that one but this
this is what I really wanted to show you
exactly VD from the ball to review epic
there yep and I was there when it was
shot you made the true story based based
on a true story
Wow would you mind telling me to tail
and stand up after I have a sip of my
storytelling sauce oh the same sauce
that makes you good at slow-mo leapfrog
with me our story begins on the
nostalgia critic sitting down at the
desk he normally does hello I'm the
Nostalgia Critic guy remember it so you
don't have to let's talk about a little
film called Balto
[Music]
despite it doing poorly with both
critics and box office the film
essentially found success on home video
leading to a ton of VHS and DVD sales so
I guess it got the reputation of the not
really little films and not really good
but turned into profit eventually so
table scraps equal for all based on the
true story it covers a dog sled they
have to race against time to get
medicine to a town full of dying
children even though it's gathered a
nostalgic following we should still ask
them so soon really hold up years later
whether it does or doesn't we're not
going to get any movies about heroic cat
sleds are we hey I read that back haha
wait a minute wait a minute there's
fucking animals Ernest sure why not I
thought you said this was a true story
based they you can get pollution ate
that they were talking animals possible
I just had a nicotine patch it's in my
daily smoking so I'm feeling a little
queasy rolling down but what about my
story okay are you gonna shut up are you
going to keep being Little Miss YouTube
comments okay
I'm sorry that's better that's a good
high anyway so Chris started his review
let's take a look at all toe so this
anime is story about a dog racing across
Alaska opens with live action people in
the middle of New York you sure we
didn't put on professor sprout visits
the muggle verse a woman and her
grandchild are looking for a memorial
sites and she besides supports the kid
to sit on a bench for an hour and a half
while she counts the story in the cold
winter of 1925
knowing hug things were animated back
then I dare even say with a Spielberg
vibe we see a lapkus portrayal has been
/ remember introduced or half wolf half
dog hybrid also played by Kevin Bacon
he's also joined by a goose played by I
think Bob Hoskins drunken rants from the
Super Mario Brothers movie it's his best
Russian accent since enemy at the gate
Stalingrad they're watching us led right
led by a dog named steel who we so mean
that literally every frame is determined
to convince you he's pure evil get out
of here we'll go back well maybe your
taste runs more toward a walnut Jenna
join me for dinner I've never seen a bad
guy where every second he's moving in
some sort of obviously diabolical manner
what oh those Don's have so normal
everyday movement but 24/7 this guy is
like would you like some ice cream and
you can trust me I'm losing blessedness
every angle is evil except for maybe
this one that that looks like a girl's
teacher from an anime con but look at
this you don't want to turn around look
evil I'm sorry Balto
Balto the happily oh you want me to turn
around okay yeah oh you want me to do it
again everybody must Balto for being a
hybrid the humans are afraid of him and
the dogs think he's an outcast waiting
to probably becomes most poignant line
oh he knows he's about T's nut Wow
actually pretty heavy how you go follow
something as complex as that up
so that just happened others also bob
hoskins doing the goose tub hey hey so
this point you're probably wondering
where does the comedy in this kid's film
lie particularly with the goose it's
this Lego Batman good are we in nutjob
territory well let's look at the chart
yeah yeah damn it just annoying enough
they've entered the simbad zone oh
there's also these I think polar bears
so they look more like Mughals at the
ancient pose that's a possibly make
things worse they're voiced by Phil
Collins when we love you uncle Foley oh
Christ
not a musical oh you are a kite movie so
what having fun at beautiful o'clock and
presumably striking a trailor pose let
me see here yep that's some compressed
enchantment bad news seems be rolling in
movie lagging need story send disease
preferably child killing there you go a
horrible epidemic seems to be sweeping
the town as rosy the woman telling the
story shown here as a kid is being
comforted by her dog Jenna played by
Bridget Fonda Rosie come on you're gonna
catch your death out here come and catch
it inside it's a stronger visual for
younger viewers hi hi in the hospital
why balton of course has the hots for
Jenna but she's too distracted by what
will happen to Rosie I don't wanna find
out come on
based on a true story if your dog can't
do that to keep stupid looks like this
area and I'm out of hand hi Tasha
yeah Jenna I'm sorry you know I'm voiced
by Kevin Bacon right and I like eating
bacon so that's like two degrees with me
does a dogsled race will be done to
determine which dogs will go out to get
the medicine would you think they'd
figure out from the races they do that
cause the factor here guys of course
though Balto enters himself in do you
honestly think anyone would ever put you
on his team you really wanna make stuff
that I thought ah she'll tell you you
from now we're gonna need what you kill
a meal will be after you do one is a
medicine get through stop being such a
glory hound your router person rides on
a night I wasn't thinking about those
children good Lord it's like its face it
and different personalities and they all
eat children told you find ways and
leave you or a cat toy then you'll be a
part of all court punchlines like this
Shane Solo Indiana Jones starts his
winter vacation the dogsled led by steel
travel through the snow to get the
medicine this is the polar not going
anywhere please hand over your one-way
ticket to kathiria maybe we just don't
back I am NOT rush yeah you know dogs
really are the worst with direction it's
like when I let my dog drive all right
just back out nice and smooth
wait a minute Kira a dog drive I guess
this true story of yours doesn't seem to
make very much sense why would anybody
let a dog drive shouldn't be the human
is doing the driving look I'm telling
the story to a kid of course I'm going
to take some creative liberties because
I think you're dumb how much of your
story is actually true but it continues
as you're talking about when one of the
dogs fifty bad my friend just how I
speak bark which I thought we were all
speaking but apparently not
it looks like the sled is missing in the
store well okay I'm sure a slight delay
won't be a major issue oh god I'd have
been real man couldn't swim in the other
coffins are for Tiny Tim little match
girl and full metal alchemist boiler
don't act like that can't happen that's
aunt in this world her fried Jesus what
do you follow a theme like that up with
when you are big frozen stiff at your
main puzzle is the comedy stylings of
characters you much rather eat and
listen to something totally appropriate
now I'm beginning to understand about Oh
a shame this isn't a musical could you
people count obnoxiously explaining in
song what doesn't need to be explained
then soften fit meet the kid's gonna die
this Colin says this is where you cry
some big emotions about love inspiration
stuff and where my paycheck I got up
ah I smell boyfriend material
jeanna figures out Balto is going to
find a sled and deliver the medicine he
marks his trail by scratching the trees
because of dog and wolf sense of smell
would just get him lost as we think
Steele gang is in big trouble
I call it let sedum come on you I
thought you never ate human flesh before
but our heroes come across the biggest
threat and animated movies a bear so
don't you know they ruin animated film
now open season brother bear brave
normal adores their destruction knows no
rewrite you're gonna wish even those
black bears go that is a pretty damn
black bear
did he bathe an egg after swimming
through oil from a lake in Sin City
he's a blanket blooded coffee but Jenna
saves the day as they leave the bear
into the ice that's right return to your
home planet whatever species you were
supposed to be
there you go go save on polar bears
rather than fight the other bear that
you should technically be bigger than
it's just like when Pluto's on a leash
but goofy can walk around we just don't
question it but Jenna damages her leg so
the comic air-quote relief take her back
while Balto moves forward eventually
meeting up with the sled I don't get it
Zach I'm the lead dog I'm in charge
- bullshit still takes drugs gambling
dogs this must be Michael Vick's
favorite scene fusible that one what
steel wants the glory so he fights Balto
despite him not fighting back thank God
kids films favorite pacifism because
steel falls off a cliff mid F beating
dead dead dead dead dead dead dead dead
oh I mean totally alive but even with
Balto leading the way Steele still mad
just to stop the medicine from getting
to dying kids go ahead wolf dog
you'll never get home come here move
away we shall run with this character
this is a village of kids that are going
to die bad dog bad dog I'm also gonna
trade three new cancers as soon as I get
home so both of us well loses his way
but it's determined to move forward
right off the cliff
well it's all okay now
okay it's all okay that was a flower
gravity was nicer to a demain character
both the movie and the concept meanwhile
back at the village the others tried to
figure out why Paulo went looking for
them he's tracking tracking a
championship team in a blizzard kids are
dying silly you got a laugh don't you
what still makes it back he tells a
little story about how Balto trying to
sabotage the mission ending up with the
other dogs getting killed I went on
dragging the medicine alone all alone
fault he demanded I let him take the
medicine could handle it he made me
promise to take care of huge it wow this
guy is such an obvious yet evil liar he
should probably get a job at the White
House the other dogs died and I was the
only one left period also the race I was
a part of it the largest audience to
ever witness a dogsled race period but
sir we have eyes your eyes are wrong
it's an alternative bark but Melissa
stop calling me that
but Jenna doesn't believe him and note
that Balto is still up there trying to
get the medicine for poor Rosie
how do you have any nicotine patches
no what the hell are you doing here I've
been coughing up a lung on your couch I
figured if I was lightheaded I wouldn't
mind so much why are you sleeping on my
couch the nice couch get out of here
go that's your only contribution to the
story it's laying in bed and coffee is
maybe how did you know that any of it
was going on then you weren't there you
didn't see it and the majority of the
junk I don't possibly made out will Chan
what am I supposed to say here and then
I looked at the ceiling longer and then
I coughed 87 more times I've got to
embellish if any of this story trills
come on is it so hard to believe that I
was lost passed out and annoying people
I guess that's a good point
speaking of which go get me some gin
from the fridge let's see how many shots
it takes to forget your name
[Music]
hey guys want to meet me the channel
awesome team and see the premiere of one
of our reviews on the big screen well
you can on May 3rd at Hollywood
Boulevard Theatre in Woodridge Illinois
we'll be premiering our clipless review
of Suicide Squad this is one of the best
movie theaters you'll ever go to it has
memorabilia themed theaters food alcohol
relaxing chairs and of course I will be
signing autographs in the lobby at 7
p.m. and start the show at 9 and we'll
even do a QA right after tickets are $20
and you can get them at the link below
at the awesome store calm show does
require the purchase of a food or drink
and we will verify purchase tickets at
the event and hand out your printed
tickets there guys we've never done this
before so we have no idea how fast
tickets are going to go so best get them
as early as you can come say hi enjoy
the show and hopefully we'll see you
there
[Music]
[Applause]
the balsa was separate from his team and
still has some medicine but comes the
crime
[Music]
Kimbo the White Wolf well that's all I
got I want a room an to us that's like
brain surgery apparently that gives him
superpowers to drag the medicine up a
cliff how do you think grandma explained
that and then the god of the wolf came
or something wait why didn't they hone
at this guy making Balto physically
stronger I guess I'm not following any
of this and even though that what could
have helped pull the sled or give
directions he just kind of disappeared
and was never seen again I hope you're
mad do they make me catch the game so
the team is back on track is also uses
his nose to find the way why Danny just
you left before is that like a weird
prejudice - dogs don't sniff to find
stuff how dare you use your nose don't
you know what disgusting animal you're
sounding like toucan sam but because
this film was to punish all signs of
hope it tries to toss them off a bridge
followed by an Evelyn oh come on the
moral of the story is nature sucks -
don't blame us know we don't something
fight back
he knows missing in the scene I'll Phil
Cowan song I'm scared of snow you should
be afraid to I fell yeah half
feel all the way through I get trapped
inside a cave where the movie reminds us
that Spielberg produced this film I'll
be right in my legal authority to
satirize this property but if it seconds
of levity was overbearing don't worry I
think us giant killer icicles are after
them now give us a fucking
oh the medicine crate has a crack in it
too
Thank You Cole this will be sex sex sex
sex against that they don't actually
make it out though and Jenna reflects
some bottles that apparently light up
the entire town which also would have
plainly seen anyway so I can avoid
[Music]
oh and a meteor hisses I'm so sorry his
life has been like this on me true it's
kind of like God it man but news reaches
deal about Balto's return which pisses
off the rest okay okay I can explain you
guys weren't there so you don't wait
guys wait a second oh come on I was
trying to do a reverse gorilla deville
you know evil dog wants to kill a bunch
of little kids so I will be on some abet
felons lest the medicine is received
Balto give they had me from his brethren
and Jenna gives him the equivalent of
dog frenching well this is such a joyous
occasion let's give Balto absolutely no
lines whatsoever yeah I'm not even
kidding
he doesn't speak in the last 25 minutes
of this movie the kind of dialogue aside
from an occasional word like poop or ah
the other dogs get a lot of lines but
for whatever reason Balto is almost
completely silent then again that might
be for the best
but everything they threw at him his
dialogue probably wouldn't be very
kid-friendly
ah shit god damn it apparently then I
run over a leprechaun what is with the
bullshit bad luck so rosy story seems to
be over as they find the monument
dedicated to the dog that made that
journey in the winter of 1925
pablor when they gave you all of that
innkeeper oh yes sweetheart he really
did I tuned I really shouldn't
Kevin let the kids have their true story
hmm Balto facts you're not gonna like it
you're really not gonna like it
Balto did not run the longest nor most
hazardous part of the journey the most
dangerous and longest run was led by a
dog named ho go driven by a musher named
Seppala in fact there were 20 mushers of
varying dogs used to make the journey
Balto
happened to be the last one so he got
the majority of the credit well set the
law oh go did the hardest work it was
Balto that got all the faith even from
President Calvin Coolidge in fact there
was such a hatred for Balto getting all
the credit that him and his owner
weren't even welcome to the award
ceremony in New York for Seppala and
Togo this is all boasting whitening well
there was an incredible review done
entirely by the nostalgia critic ah
there it is about time I thumbed the
sucker
wait a minute the salsa critic is still
alive and you ever even filmed the
reviewing it well no random kid I was
just about to divide to get the script
from my brother
you see I was sick so he wrote the
majority of it this week oh my god so
we're not even in the future are we
you're a special kid aren't you but what
about the text that says we are oh
that's just my satanic heart why not
practically everything okay look maybe
everything didn't happen like I said
maybe credit was given to the wrong
person and maybe like 98% of what you
heard was false but did you have fun I
guess was it corny but beautiful at
times I suppose and did you know
anything at all about these dogs saving
kids before I told you not really well
then for for most of this out of my ass
I'd say we had a pretty entertaining
time I never thought of it like that
hey critic what did you think of also by
the way basically that oh well maybe
there's more truth to fiction than I
thought actually there isn't now just a
huge coincidence you know which why did
you bring her to begin with oh I just
wanted to leave her here so I didn't
have to tell her the both parents died
from double erotic asphyxiation well
that backfired you know your critic what
trip to exile point is very delicate
don't worry I know a certain long face
balding big tooth comedian who would
love to take care of you oh no yours
Chester oh my god I'm a mother
[Music]
[Applause]
well maybe your taste runs more toward a
wolf
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing the one
acre fund this organization empowers
chronically hungry farm families in East
Africa to lift themselves out of hunger
and poverty they supply smallholder
farms with the financing and training
they need to grow their way out they
invest in farmers to generate a
permanent gain in farm income that means
they provide a complete service bundle
of feeds and fertilizer financing
training and deliver these services
within walking distance of the 400,000
rural farmers they serve they measured
success and their ability to make
farmers more prosperous and they always
put the farmers first if you go to their
YouTube page you can see all the various
people they've helped in the past and if
you go to their site you can see how you
can help them in their missions click on
the link and see how you can grow
something really special
[Music]
you